- [Kelly:] I'm just curious
with a voice like yours,
like were people just like, 'oh my God?'
from childhood with you?
Like do you remember
the first time you sang?
- [Ann Wilson:] Well, uh...
- People were floored.
- My family was super musical.
We had all these aunts
and uncles and everything.
We always loved to play,
like get together and play the ukuleles,
and sing the old songs and stuff.
And so it was pretty
easy just to go from that
to being asked to sing
at one of my parents' cocktail parties.
- It was fluid.
Yeah, you're really used to it.
- It wasn't much of a stretch really.
- Yeah.
- And as a little kid,
you know little kids loved to show off
in front of the grownups, you know?
- Yeah. 'Look at me!'
- Yeah. Well, yeah.
'I'm funny. Right?'
- Yeah.
- You know, and so I used to do this,
I think from early age like six to eight,
I was doing this rendition
of the Hawaiian Wedding Song
as Ethel Merman.
So it was like a child, you know?
So I think that's where
I got the sort of feeling
that singing and acting go together.
- Yeah. Oh, I do agree with that.
Like while I'm singing,
but are you like thi-
Because I hate acting, but I love-
I feel like I do it on stage
because you jump into character
of wherever you were
when you wrote the song.
- Yeah, yeah.
That ever hard for you
depending upon this song?
- For me, it's not the
songs that are too intense.
It's the ones that I've grown out of.
- Ah.
- Like, you know
I don't want to say anything
about too specific songs, but-
- You don't want to like poo
poo on the songs, but yeah.
- But a song like magic man, you know.
- Yeah.
- Was written way back when I
was in my super early twenties
and with my first love. and-
- Don't you bash Magic
Man right now, ma'am.
- That's what I meant.
- I will actually tackle you.